est-ce que la CIA c'est des choses que
les présidents ne savent pas
où est-ce qu'il est obligé de tout dire
au président
alors vous avez 50 ans bobber et vous
êtes un excadre de la CIA
alors vous êtes en train de la CIA en
1976 pourquoi un jeune homme chic
habitué à faire du ski à Aspen et à
faire des voyages en Europe a-t-il
postulé pour entrer à la ciao oui
c'était super romantique
comment comment vous vous appelez
Monsieur Olivier un bonsoir Olivier
bonsoir bien alors
pourquoi avoir quitté la CIA 20 ans plus
tard
et aussi
à mon goût et donc j'avais l'impression
de perdre mon temps
et donc j'ai tenté ma chance ailleurs
bien alors pendant 20 ans vous avez
combattu l'islamisme sur tous les fronts
c'est surtout ça
en Irak
en 95 j'ai essayé de faire tomber Saddam
je vais monter une petite équipe au nord
de l'Irak malheureusement ça n'a pas été
un succès
dépêche-toi un peu Olivier lassaut bien
est-ce que la CIA c'est des choses que
les présidents ne savent pas
où est-ce qu'il est obligé de tout dire
au président
[Musique]
sont pas au courant mais bon ça on en
parle pas du tout
et c'est très rare
mais bon je peux pas tout vous dire
bien alors le pitch va vous révéler
bobberg il y a un pacte qui unit les
élites économiques et politiques
américaines à la famille royale
saoudienne voilà en gros c'est ce qui
ressort de votre qui ressort de votre
bouquin alors dans votre livre il y a
des passages qui sont supprimés il est
passage qui sont caviardés alors vous
les avez vous les avez laissés mais
barré quoi c'est à dire vous êtes obligé
de montrer tout ce que vous écrivez à la
CIA
o
il a fallu
retire certains passages l'essentiel est
là et je remercie la CIA d'ailleurs
alors il y avait quoi dans dans ces
passages barrés
dans les années 70 dans les années 80
il y avait un soutien officiel des
États-Unis au fondamentaliste islamiste
soviétique l'Afghanistan c'est un
exemple que nous connaissons tous
principalement c'est ça
qui existaient dans le passé et qui sont
un petit peu gênantes à l'heure actuelle
alors bobber votre livre est dédié à
Daniel perle qui est le héros du dernier
livre de Bernard Henri Lévy dont il est
venu parler ici alors Bernard il est vit
à tiré l'attention sur le sur le
Pakistan vous c'est l'Arabie Saoudite
alors l'Arabie Saoudite très simplement
pour nos amis téléspectateurs c'est un
quart des réserves de pétrole du monde
et c'est vrai que l'arrêt de
l'approvisionnement en pétrole saoudien
serait la mort d'une grave crise
mondiale c'est pour ça en fait que
depuis très longtemps il y a une
alliance entre les États-Unis et
l'Arabie Saoudite qui a été signé au
départ entre Roosevelt et le roi Émile
Séoul en gros c'est ce que vous appelez
pétrole contre protection et deuxième
raison de cette alliance c'est que les
Saoudiens l'islam en général était un
rempart contre le communisme du temps de
la guerre froide c'est ça et c'est ce
qui explique ce que vous appelez dans
votre bouquin l'aveuglement américain
par rapport à l'Arabie Saoudite
on voit qu'il y a une dépendance totale
de l'économie américaine vis-à-vis de
l'Arabie Saoudite prenons par exemple
une grève au Venezuela les puits de
pétrole sont fermés et bien à ce moment
là qui va compenser l'Arabie Saoudite
évidemment qui
qui a pu
l'armée américaine est bien tout
simplement
l'Arabie Saoudite dans la mesure où
c'est leur premier acheteur
l'Arabie Saoudite investit des milliards
de dollars dans l'économie américaine
vous savez
dès lors qu'il y a accoutumance il est
difficile de voir les choses en face
donc il y a un lien qui date d'une
cinquantaine d'années entre l'Arabie
Saoudite et les États-Unis pour des
raisons qu'on a vu et depuis le 11
septembre la réalité est apparue aux
yeux de tous c'est que la famille royale
saoudienne est totalement corrompu
complètement corrompu et pour garder le
pouvoir elle finance les extrémistes
c'est ça c'est ça l'histoire a commencé
par Al-Qaïda
bien sûr c'est tout simplement
il leur verse de l'argent
fondamentaliste pour
pour se protéger et puis leur dit en
fait je révolution ailleurs en Afrique
en Asie en Indonésie ou ailleurs mais
pas ici
le mieux la meilleure c'est que ça a
marché au bout du compte et en fait il y
a pas eu de difficultés en Arabie
Saoudite
le problème en fait c'est à Washington
si vous voulez savoir toute la vérité à
mon avis c'est que Washington voit les
choses tout à fait différemment
et donc le 11 septembre
surpris de voir qu'il y avait 15
ressortissants d'Arabie Saoudite dans
ses avions alors lénine avait dit les
capitalistes nous vendront l'accord pour
les pour les pendres finalement c'est un
peu ce que font les Américains puisque
l'attentat du World Trade Center a été
financé finalement avec de l'argent
américain d'une certaine façon
absolument vous savez que l'argent
utilisé au 11 septembre dans le cas des
attentats du 11 septembre avait été
prélevé en Arabie Saoudite etc et
ensuite il a été réinjecté en fait
chaque fois que on fait son plein on
fait le plein de sa voiture de sa
voiture et bien on donne de l'argent
Al-Qaïda
bon alors bien évidemment on peut
toujours essayer de savoir qui fait quoi
etc mais bon c'est un fait Bernard
tout ça est vrai pour le pétrole mais le
pétrole c'est pas seulement l'argent
américain c'est l'argent du monde c'est
notre argent c'est l'argent de tous les
pays nous nous fournissons également en
Arabie Saoudite mais ce qui est très
étonnant son bouquin c'est pourquoi les
américains sont-ils victimes d'un tel
aveuglement et bien vous dites parce
qu'ils sont encore rompus eux aussi bien
sûr le recyclage des Petro de l'art mais
aussi tout un tas à Washington de
lobbyistes de cabinets de relations
publiques d'avocats vous dites par
exemple c'est des petits exemples mais
le roi fade envoie un million de dollars
à Barbara bouge pour ses œuvres en
faveur de l'alphabétisation par exemple
vous dites aussi une histoire qui est
bien pire que ça c'est qu'un jour
cachogi va dans le ranch de Nixon à San
clémenter en Californie et puis en
partant il oublie une valise avec un
million de dollars à l'intérieur
personne a lui réclame il en déduit ils
en déduisent
que finalement Washington est à vendre
quoi quelle est la solution pour régler
le problème de l'Arabie Saoudite alors
au départ on s'est dit la démocratie la
démocratie viendra à bout de tous les
problèmes mais vous dites aujourd'hui
que s'il y avait des élections libres en
Arabie Saoudite finalement compte tenu
la nature du pays ça serait des
islamistes qui seraient élus et que
l'Arabie Saoudite deviendra un pays
comme comme l'Iran de romeini par
exemple
ce qu'il faut mettre en place en Arabie
Saoudite c'est l'état de droit dans un
premier temps il faut essayer d'aider
les classes moyennes pour qu'il y ait un
accès un droit à la propriété
c'est une première étape nécessaire
et puis il faut aussi se débarrasser de
toute cette corruption c'est vraiment
c'est ridicule
c'est pas la solution donc la solution
c'est quoi c'est l'intervention
militaire contre l'Arabie Saoudite
le devoir d'un gérant
à la fin du livre je fais un petit
raccourci
et je dis que si le pays fait faillite
et bien à ce moment-là on peut pas
perdre ce pays parce que on a besoin de
ce pétrole pour des raisons de sécurité
mais ce qu'il faudrait qu'il y ait c'est
des réformes au sein du pays il y a une
aile qui soit très formée le pays c'est
celle représentée par le prince héritier
est-ce que c'est bobber est-ce que c'est
parce qu'ils sentent que l'attitude des
États-Unis à leur égard est en train de
de changer que l'Arabie Saoudite se
rapproche on l'a vu cette semaine se
rapproche de la Russie
oui je pense que l'Arabie Saoudite se
rend bien compte que
on est en train de dire clairement que
les relations entre les deux pays vont
de mal empire
et donc on se rend compte qu'il y a une
superpuissance qui d'un coup de queue
tel un dinosaure pour aller renverser
donc je pense que l'Arabie Saoudite est
en train de rechercher de nouveaux
alliés que ce soit la Russie ou l'Europe
ou en Europe
les États-Unis n'oublie jamais
ou il ne faut jamais oublier que les
États-Unis ont été profondément blessés
par les attentats du 11 septembre c'est
un fait les Américains ont été vraiment
touchés et donc il est clair aux yeux
des Américains et aux yeux du reste du
monde d'ailleurs que tout le monde que
les États-Unis ont su réagi en quelque
sorte et donc on se rend compte que cela
a affecté leur relation avec l'Arabie
Saoudite alors quand vous parlez des
États-Unis ce qui est le plus inquiétant
à mon sens c'est que vous dites qui sont
tellement corrompus par l'argent
saoudien qu'on voit pas très bien
comment il pourrait s'arrêter d'être
aveuglé d'une certaine façon alors
qu'est-ce qui pourrait se passer aux
États-Unis un sursaut mais les médias
aux États-Unis maintenant sont très
embrigadés on voit bien il y a plus
qu'une seule voie qui parle il y a aux
États-Unis de plus en plus
d'arrestations arbitraire la BS corpus
qui est la base de notre démocratie et
remis en cause aux États-Unis alors je
voudrais vous poser une question bobber
une question qui a été cette semaine
elle a une d'un magazine qui s'appelle
Marianne qui est le magazine de
Jean-François Kahn
Bob
ber est-ce que vous croyez sérieusement
aujourd'hui que les États-Unis sont
encore une démocratie
[Musique]
encore une attaque et cette attaque
pourrait avoir des dommages irréparables
des conséquences très graves et je pense
que tout le monde s'en inquiète
donc l'Amérique est à peine une
démocratie dites-vous
une démocratie mais s'il y avait une
attaque de plus et à ce moment-là on
verra un certain nombre de droits
disparaitre
mais espérons que tel ne sera pas le cas
on rallume Bernard non c'est quand même
curieux qu'on s'en aperçoit maintenant
tout le monde sait depuis 25 ans que les
Saoudite et saoudiens
persécute tout le monde que les droits
de l'homme ne sont pas respectés que les
femmes peuvent pas conduire que tout ça
a été épouvantable découvrir cela juste
conduisent pas c'est pas mal
Bernard sauf que sauf que
sauf que maintenant en plus on découvre
qui finance Al-Qaïda enfin tout le monde
le savait c'est avec eux qu'ils ont fait
l'Afghanistan les talibans etc donc on
découvre pas ça maintenant parce que
c'était vraiment la fable
comme ça vous vous créez des ennemis
dangereux
il y a tellement de gens qui sont
furieux là furieux
mais bon les gens ne vont pas chercher à
se venger contre une famille
tout simplement merci
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de tube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu